amazon i want to know what uh
what our friend here vinnie has to say
so amazon says it's going to start
making prime deliveries by drone later
this year in
california okay is that a good idea or a
bad idea another insider story so amazon
packages you receive later this year
could be delivered by a drone not a
driver at least if you live in lachlan
lockerford
lockford california customers there will
be uh seeing items available for prime
air delivery on amazon they'll make
purchase as usual and a drone will fly
to the designated delivery location the
device will descend into the customer's
backyard hover hover and release the
package and fly back again amazon says
this drones have a sense
and avoid system that helps them spot
both stationary and moving objects to
avoid colliding with people pets other
aircrafts other obstacles
the drones
course correct if they identify
obstacles in order to avoid them and
when descending at a customer's home
they make sure the surrounding area is
empty for landing do you believe i don't
trust any of that [ __ ]
first of all like think about eli it's
not like elon musk is do behind this
technology and even his cars have been
crashing and doing whatever but brooke
like can you just imagine the excuses
for like
where's my package i can't like listen
out of our control a hawk attacked the
[ __ ] out of your thing it fell into them
and just think about it and think about
it malfunctioning and falling on people
like and how big how big of a package
are they saying that they're going to be
sending i mean what how big is it did
they specify they didn't say microwave
no you know just baseballs like what are
they what are they saying but i don't
trust it i mean
if we're if we're 10 12 years old and
you got a bb gun you're a kid dude
that's like target practice
imagine the problems are gonna come what
are you going to maneuver like a bb gun
like this like legit drone yeah what do
you think i i don't think it's going to
be insane
like there's enough stuff in the sky
like with airplanes and stuff it's like
you're now gonna have drones flying
around it's scary bro trust uh
i trust jeff bezos
i think he's gonna figure it out
you're the only one tyler pull up this
website
it's
relentless.com that's his website no no
this is relentless.com what do you
think's gonna come up
relentless.com
boom goes to amazon this guy
ain't
stopping he's figured it out he'll
continue to figure it out
look elon musk gets all the headlines
he's dating the you know the women he's
doing all the right you know but
loki
jeff bezos
is that you adam i'm just saying no i'm
definitely not the local guy i'm more
the the loudmouth guy you know vinnie no
you know what it's like
but i think this guy's gonna figure it
out i think he's got a long-term vision
if i get hit in the head with a fallen
package from amazon i'm suing this shirt
let me ask you this how much of this do
you think about if you're listening i'm
curious i want to hear your commentary
how much of this do you think it's us
uh not wanting to embrace change
and how much of it is just weird period
no it's weird listen let me just
announce this now keep the drones off my
lawn
all like did i ever tell you the story
in brooklyn when jeremy was butt naked
walking through the apartment in the
drone no oh yeah jeremy's at home like
yeah i saw the photos oh my business
my mother said that to him he was like
my mother had an exchange with him once
when she was like oh i heard about the
drone and he's like did you see it on
the internet he was so paranoid his
pictures his nude pictures are gonna be
on the internet but yeah they were
surveilling my building and they just
didn't tell us they were doing something
and it just rose up and jeremy was butt
naked i was like no i'm out on dru all
this stuff i'm out on ai interesting i'm
out yeah i'm out i don't need it i will
what is it so hard to go get your
packages at the front i mean you know
what i'm saying why do you have to
modernize everything why does everything
need to look like this all those drivers
are gonna be you know going to be less
drivers
it all comes down to this are you a
flintstones girl or are you a jetsons
girl you guys know the flintstones i
don't need to fly i don't need to get in
my car
you sound in very stunning give me some
bamboo sound sounding very boomer back
in my day me and fred stone not that old
jed you all know i would hop into
delorean tyler knows and go back to 1985
if i could but no there's some things
that just don't need to be modern this
will be abused my answer to you is that
this sounds all cool right now sounds
great sounds fun reality glasses you put
them on you're like oh there i am in an
alternate universe give it a minute it
will be abused there will be
surveillance this thing will be on when
it's not supposed to be on they're
watching us so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]